[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم ليلى في
الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث وتتفاعل
اخرى والبدايه مع هذه الصور للاحتجاجات
المستمره بين معسكرين في تل ابيب على
الرغم من تاجيل نتنياهو التصويت على
التعديلات القضائيه
اما هذه الصور فتاتي مباشره من ولايه
تلاسي الجنوبيه في الولايات المتحده
تحديدا من مدينه ناشبال حيث قتل سته اشخاص
في اطلاق نار في مدرسه هنا وهي حادثه تعيد
الى الواجهه مساله اقتناء الاسلحه في
الولايات المتحده
اما هذه الصور فهي تاتيكم من مكه المكرمه
واجواء الحرم في شهر رمضان وايضا انتهاء
الصلاه التراويح تقبل الله صيامكم
وفي مواضيع الحساد هذه الليله
في هروب الى الامام رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي يؤجلوا التصويت على التعديلات
القضائيه ويتفق مع وزير الامن على تمرير
ما يسمى مشروع الحرس الوطني واستقلق من
انشاء ميليشيا خاصه
تحذر من تحايل نتنياهو في قرار التجميد
ووزير الخارجيه يقول انه لن يتم السماح
باندلاع حرب اهليه
على الرغم من استمرار مظاهرات معسكر
المعارضه ومعسكر اليمين النقابات العماليه
تعلق اضراباتها رئيس الاركان الاسرائيلي
يطالب الجنود بمواصله اداء واجبهم
ونتنياهو يحذر من رفض الخدمه الشيكل
يتراجع امام الدولار الاداره الامريكيه
تحث الاطراف على الوصول لحل وسط وتقول ان
مزاعم تمويل واشنطن للاحتجاجات باطله ولا
اساس لها
مزيد من الدعم الغربي نحو اوكرانيا بعد
اقرار تفاهمات اوروبيه بشان تسريع
الامدادات العسكريه المانيا ترسل ثمانيه
عشر دبابه لابرد اثنين واربعين عربه مدرعه
وبعد جدل بشان ارسال سلاح نووي تكتيكي الى
بيلاروسيا يقول ان انتقادات الغرب لن تثني
موسكو عن قرارها
تصف القرار الروسي بالتصعيد وتدعو لرد
هادئ وحازم
[موسيقى]
وفي السودان الجزيره تحصل على نسخه من
الاتفاق الايطالي النهائي بين العسكريين
في السلطه وقوى مدنيه والاتفاق يؤكد على
ضروره انجاز الاصلاح الامني بما يقود الى
جيش مهنيا موحد ينقى عن السياسه والتجاره
والمسوده تنص على اطلاق عمليه شامله تحقق
العداله الانتقاليه ومحاسبه وكشف الجرائم
ومحاسبه مرتكبيها
وفي لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد ناقشنا معكم
على منصاتنا الرقميه قرار رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو تجميد التصويت
على التعديلات القضائيه التي تحد من نفوذ
السلطه القضائيه لصالح الكنيست ورئاسه
الوزراء وذلك لمده شهر في محاوله لوقف
الاحتجاجات التي باتت تزعزع تحالفه
الحكوميه وتقسم الاسرائيليين بين معسكرين
نتنياهو صدر اعلانه عن قرار التجميد بحديث
صارم عن التصدي لاي عصيان في المؤسسه
العسكريه ومحاولات رفض الخدمه
لاستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا
طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي هل سيتصاعد
الانقسام الاسرائيلي بين معسكرين
63% قالوا ان حده الانقسام ستزيد بينما
صوت 37% لصالح خيار حل الخلافات
هذا سؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الذي يظهر الان على الشاشه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اهلا يا رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين
نتنياهو انه قررت تعليق تشريع التغييرات
القضائيه التي من شانها ان تحد من صلاحيات
سلطه القضاء وفي كلمه القاها الليله اكد
نتنياهو اصرار حكومته على اجراء التعديلات
القضائيه معلنا انه قرر تعليق القراءتين
القادمهتين للقانون وعلل نتنياهو قراره
بان اسرائيل على مفترق طرق خطير وان
الازمه تلزم الجميع بالتصرف بمسؤوليه حسب
تعبيره واعتبر رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيليه
ان هناك اقليه متطرفه مستعده لتقسيم الشعب
الاسرائيلي كما قال وحذر من ان اسرائيل
تمضي في مسار
للصدام المجتمعي مؤكدا انه لم يقبل اندلاع
حرب اهليه في اسرائيل
ومع استمرار المظاهرات بين المعسكرين قال
وزير الخارجيه الاسرائيلي اليكوهن انه لم
يتم السماح باندلاع حرب اهليه ياتي ذلك
فيما علقت نقابات العماليه اضراباتها غدا
واستتراجع لاسعار الشيكل مقابل الدولار
هذه الصور المباشره تاتيكم للاحتجاجات
المستمره حيث تحاول الشرطه تفرقه
المتظاهرين واضح خراطيم المياه
[تصفيق]
اذا صور مباشره كما نشاهد ما زالت
الاحتجاجات قائمه وذلك بعد خطاب الرئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي الليله شاهدنا اذا
محاولات لفض هذه الاحتجاجات من خلال
استعمال خراطيم المياه من قبل قوات الشرطه
على العموم سنتابع معكم هذه المشاهد
المستمره وردود الفعل عليها
والتحليلات المختلفه بشانها والى اين يمكن
ان تفضي اترككم مع الصور
[موسيقى]
في ابرز ردود الفعل الاسرائيليه قال
الرئيس الاسرائيلي اسحاق هرتسك ان وقف
التشريعات هو الشيء الصحيح وانه حان الوقت
لبدء حوار جاد لخفض التوتر وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيليه المقال يؤث جالنت اعرب بدوره
عن ترحيبه بقرار وقف التشريعات لصالح
المفاوضات اما زعيم المعارضه
فاعلن الاستعداد للحوار لدى الرئيس وفق
منحا محدد والسعي لانجاز دستورا لاسرائيل
على اساس وثيقه الاستقلال كما حذر لابيد
في تصريحات له من انه اذا حاولنا نتنياهو
الخداع فانه سيجد نفسه مره اخرى امام مئات
الالاف من المتظاهرين
[موسيقى]
وننوه بهذا الخبر الذي يصلنا عن طريق
مراسلنا بان
القائمون بهذه الاحتجاجات يقولون انهم
سيواصلون وذلك لان هدفهم هو الغاء
التعديلات وليس التاجيل كما ورد الان تنضم
الينا من القدس مراسلتنا نجوان سمري ومن
تل ابيب مراسلنا احمد هزيم اذا من المهم
ان نعرف ما الذي يجري في الشارع الان سواء
عندك نجوان او احمد تفضلي ابدئي نجوان
نعم ليلى هنا في محيط الكنيست الاسرائيلي
حيث شاهد هذا اليوم مظاهره اشارك بها اكثر
من 100 الف متظاهر امام الكنيست للاحتجاج
على الاجراءات المتعلقه باحداث تغيير على
الجهاز القضائي تفرق المتظاهرون قبل قليل
والان نرى بان ايضا القوات الكبيره للشرطه
الاسرائيليه والقوات الخاصه من حرس الحدود
بدات تنسحب ايضا من هذه المنطقه التي امنت
هذه المظاهرات هذا اليوم بعد خطاب نتنياهو
بدات هذه المظاهره بالتفرق وربما كان
الاعتقاد السائد بان هذه المظاهرات بدات
بالتفرق بالتفرق بعد ان اعلن نتنياهو بانه
سيقوم بارجاء التصويت على القوانين
المتعلقه برزمه قوانين التغييرات وال في
الجهاز القضائي لكن قبل قليل فقط صدر بيان
عن منظمي هذه الاحتجاجات في اسرائيل
وقالوا بانها طالما انه لا يوجد اعلان عن
الغاء
لكل هذه الخطه الحكوميه فانهم سيواصلون
المعركه بحسب بيان صادر قبل قليل عن منظمي
هذه الاحتجاجات وقالوا بان خطاب ان
نتنياهو جاء بهذه الطريقه لاضعاف هذه
الاحتجاجات والهدف في النهايه هو تشريع ما
وصفوه بقوانين ديكتاتوريه اذا هذا هو
البيان الصادر قبل قليل من منظمي
الاحتجاجات الذين بداوا بهذه الاحتجاجات
منذ قرابه ثلاثه اشهر يقولون بانهم
سيواصلون بتنظيم المظاهرات والاحتجاجات
حتى يتم الاعلان عن الغاء تام لهذه الخطه
الحكوميه نتنياهو هذا اليوم اعلن عن ارجاء
التوجه الى الحوار مع الاطراف الاخرى خلال
هذه الفتره كان من المتوقع او من المخطط
ان يتم التصويت على احد القوانين
الاساسيه ضمن هذه التشريعات هذا اليوم بعد
ان اقرته لجنه التشريعات والدستور التابعه
للكنيست صباح هذا اليوم المتعلق بلجنه
تعيين القضاه لكن تم تاجيل ذلك ولن يتم
التصويت عليه قبل خروج الكنيست في اجازه
الاعياد اليهوديه مده شهر بعدها كما قال
نتنياهو في خطابها هذه الليله سيتم البحث
مجددا في هذه
التشريعات على امل ان يتم التواصل بحسب ما
قال على صيغه توافقيه بينهم وبين المعارضه
من اجل فرد او تشريع هذه ال ال التشريعات
المتعلقه باضعاف الجهاز القضائي كما
يسميها المحتاج لكن دعيني فقط لان غالبيه
المعارضين او زعماء المعارضه تحدثوا بلهجه
لم تخلو من التوجس وعدم الثقه باعلان
نتنياهو ربما يفسر لا يثقون ان يلتزم هو
وحكومته بالقرار الذي اعلن عنه
[موسيقى]
ان الاحتجاجات امام الكنيست والمتظاهر
والمظاهرات تم تفريقها ولكن الوضع يبدو
مختلف تماما حيث يقف احمد احمد انت المشهد
عندك مختلف وقبل قال قليل شاهدنا الشرطه
تستخدم خراطيم المياه لتفريق المتظاهرين
ولكن يبدو انهم ما زالوا متجمعين تفضل
نعم ليلى هي معركه مستمره منذ نصف ساعه
تقريبا تحاول قوات الامن باستخدام الخياله
وخراطيم المياه لتفريق هؤلاء المتظاهرين
بضعه منهم الان نسمع اصوات القنابل فراغيه
تستخدمها قوات الامن لتفريق المتظاهرين
يغادرون الساحه تاره ومن ثم يعودون اليها
من من مفرق اخر لكن يبدو ان قوات الامن
الان لتمكنت على الاقل في هذه اللحظه
باستخدام خراطيم المياه كما ترونها
وباستخدام
فرق الخياله تحاول ان تفرق المتظاهرين قد
فرقت قد استبد تمكنت من تفريق الغالبيه
منهم
تشاهدون الخياله هنا على الشاشه وهنا كما
تشاهدون هي سياره التي
خراطيم المياه التي تستخدم التي تفرق
بتظاهره لكن هذه هذا المشهد التي شاهدتموت
ليلى ليس ليس مشهدا فريدا هذا المشهد
يتكرر منذ نصف ساعه تقريبا ياتي تاتي فرق
الخيال تاتي قوات الامن تفرغ هذه الساحه
وما ان تدير ظهرها حتى يلتف عليها
المتظاهرون ويملاون الساحه من جديد من
مواقع اخرى هم في اصرارهم هذا ليله هي
الرساله التي توجه سواء الى احزاب
المعارضه او حتى الى الائتلاف بقياده
نتنياهو واحزاب اليمين الكل هنا اليوم بعد
خطاب نتنياهو حاول اعطاء فرصه للسياسيين
للوصول الى حل وسط سواء اخذنا في الاعتبار
الغاء الاضرابات العامه سواء من النقابات
او المجالس المحليه او البلديات او حتى
اعلان والتصريحات زعماء معارضه الذين
اكدوا بانهم مستعدون للحوار هؤلاء
المتظاهرون باصرارهم البقاء في هذه الساحه
يوجهون هذه الرساله بالقول كما ذكرت
الزميله نجوان بالقول بان ليست المساله
مساله
فحوى التغيير المساله الغاء هذه الخطه
بكاملها لانها هي المطيه التي يريد منها
اليمين حسب ما يقولون الوثوب على الحكم
هنا في اسرائيل وتغيير طبيعه الدوله
الاسرائيليه من دوله علمانيه ديمقراطيه
الى دوله حكم ديكتاتوري ديني ليلى الى اي
حد يتم استعمال العنف مع هؤلاء المحتاجين
هل شاهدت مثلا عدا فرق الخياله وخراطيم
المياه هل تستخدم العصي ما مدى محاولات
التفريق درجه
الجهود التي تبدل
[موسيقى]
اضافه الى الخياله وخراطيم تستخدم القنابل
او العيره الفراغيه والعيره الصوتيه
لتفريق المتظاهرين ومحاوله لغلق بعض
الشوارع لكي لا يعودوا منها لكن قوى الامن
اعداد قوى الامن الموجوده هنا في هذه
الساحه اقل بكثير من القدره على السيطره
على قوات على على هذه المتظاهرين ونحن نرى
الان كيف فرقوهم وسترون في الصوره الان
كيف عادوا من مفرق اخر
نسمع الان قنابل صوتيه ليلى
وعفوا لها لها دخان
نعم هي معركه هي كروه فار من على اكثر من
مفرق واكثر من طريق واكثر من مدخل على هذه
الساحه كلما حاولت قوات الامن افريقيا من
المتظاهرين يعودون اليها من تاريخ لاخر
ليلا واضح المشهد شكرا لك على هذه
التوضيحات احمد من تل ابيب وشكرا طبعا
لنجوان من القدس سنعود اليكما في حال
استجدت اي جديد بالنسبه لي هذا المشهد
المتصاعد كان وزير الامن القومي اتمار بن
جفير قال في تغريده انه اتفق مع نتنياهو
على تاجيل التعديلات القضائيه مقابل
التصديق على انشاء الحرس الوطني وقال ان
الاصلاحات قلب الاصلاحات سيتم تمريرها
وسيقام الحرس الوطني كما ستتم المصادقه
على الموازنه التي طلبها لوزاره الامن
القومي وشدد بن جفير على انه لا احد
باستطاعته تغيير موقف الشعب او اخافته حسب
تعبيره
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وفيما يتعلق بالمؤسسه العسكريه دعا رئيس
هيئه الاركان اركان الجيش الاسرائيلي
الجنود الى مواصله اداء واجبهم والتصرف
بمسؤوليه في مواجهه الانقسامات الاجتماعيه
المريره وقال هاليزي في تصريحات نشرها
المكتب الاعلامي العسكري ان هذه الاوقات
مختلفه عن اي اوقات شهدناها من قبل
واضافها ان اسرائيل لم تشهد توالي مثل هذه
الايام المليئه بالتهديدات الخارجيه بينما
تتشكل عاصفه في الداخل بحسب البيان
الاسرائيلي
هذا ورحبت الخارجيه الامريكيه باعلان
نتنياهو مشيره الى ان ذلك سيفتح المجال
للتوصل الى حل وسط في اسرائيل ونفت
الخارجيه الامريكيه مزاعم تمويل واشنطن
للاحتجاجات وصفه اياها بالباطله وانها لا
اساس لها وكان منسق الاتصالات
الاستراتيجيه في البيت الابيض جون كيربي
قال ان الاداره الامريكيه تراقب التطورات
في اسرائيل عن كتب وبقلق بالغ وتحث قادتها
على التوصل الى التسويه كما اضاف كرربي ان
اداره الرئيس جو بايدن يساورها قلق عميق
بشان الاحداث في اسرائيل وتتواصل مع
السلطات هناك كما قال ان الرئيس بايدن
ابدى مخاوفه لرئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
مباشره مؤكدا ان الرئيس ليس قلقا من
احتمال اندلاع حرب اهليه في اسرائيل ولا
يتوقع ذلك
ومعنى الان مباشره من البيت الابيض
مراسلتنا وجد وقفي ليس قلقا من اندلاع حرب
اهليه هذا ما يقوله بيضا ولكنه قلق ما
درجه القلق الامريكي هنا وجد
قلق بالغ وقلق عميق عبر عنهما البيت
الابيض سواء كان على لسان بمنسق الاتصالات
استراتيجيه او كارين جانبير المتحدثه باسم
البيت الابيض كلاهما تحدث عن مراقبه
الاحداث في اسرائيل يوم امس بالكثير من
القلق البالغ وبان لان اسرائيل لم سبق وان
شهدت اضطرابات داخليه بهذا الحجم بحسب
المسؤولين الامريكيين كذلك هناك اسرار من
قبل الاداره الامريكيه على ضروره ان يتوصل
قاده الى اسرائيل الى تسويه توافق عليها
اغلبيه الاسرائيليين وليس فقط جهه معينه
هذه التسويه يجب ان تحترم قيم الديمقراطيه
المبنيه على الشفافيه والمحاسبه كما ذكر
المتحدث او منسق للصلاه استراتيجيه طبعا
كما تعلمين الى هذه الاصلاحات الدستوريه
هي ستكون مثل
طوق النجاه
لنتنياهو ربما من القضايا التي يحاكم
عليها كالفساد والرشا وما تؤكد عليه
الاداره الامريكيه انما من احد محصن من
القانون وبانه ينبغي احترام قيم
الديمقراطيه المتحدثه باسم البيت الابيض
اعتبرت بان التاجيل الذي اعلن عنه
نتنياهو يمكن ان يكون فرصه من اجل قاده
اسرائيل ان يجلسوا معا وان يتواصلوا فيما
بينهم ويتفقوا على شكل التسويه التي سترضي
الاغلبيه في اسرائيل ليله اشكرك وجد وقفي
من واشنطن شكرا
ورغم تجميد نتنياهو التعديلات القضائيه
فان الانقسام الحاصل في اسرائيل لن يتوقف
عند هذه الازمه التي اثرت بشكل كبير على
الاقتصاد وعلى سير الحياه في البلاد
[موسيقى]
خوف يدفع بالالاف نحو الشوارع في اسرائيل
تستوحي هذه الفتيات شخصيات الايماء من
روايات امريكيه احداث خياليه في الولايات
المتحده بعد سيطره اليمين المتطرف على
مفاصل الحكم يتحول الجميع في الروايه الى
خدم للمشروع الايديولوجي المتطرف هذا ما
يخشاه هؤلاء في شوارع تل ابيب والقدس كما
يقولون
[موسيقى]
يرى عشرات الاف المحتاجين هنا ان تعديلات
نتنياه القضائيه هي جزء من كابوس سيغير
شكل البلاد تلك تعديلات يقول معارضها انها
تمكن اليمين من السيطره بشكل دكتاتوري على
كل شيء ينقسم الشارع السياسي في اسرائيل
يمينا التمسك بالتعديلات من رئيس الوزراء
واعضاء الائتلاف الحاكم في مقدمتهم لتمر
بنجفير وبيتسل يقولون انها خطه للاصلاح
القضائي يسارا رفض للتعديلات من رئيس
الحكومه السابق وحلفائه في الوسط واليسار
وهي مقدمتهم وزير الدفاع السابق بنجانتس
يقولون انها بدايه النهايه للديمقراطيه
بين الطرفين شد وجذب يرتكز على قواعده
ايديولوجيه بدرجه اساسيه تدخل معركه عض
الاصابع مرحله حساسه تزيد من الازمه دعوات
الاضرابات التي شملت قطاعات عده تعلن
السفارات الاسرائيليه التوقف عن العمل
ينعكس الامر نفسه على القطاع الطبي وقطاعي
النقل البحري والجوي والجامعات ومراكز
التسوق البنوك الكبرى اعلن ميناء اسدود
وحيثا التوقف عن العمل فعلى الامر نفسه
مطار بن غوريون فتوقفت حركه الطيران اغلقت
مراكز تسوق كبرى ابوابها وكذلك فعل بل كان
رئيسيا ستتوقف الحركه في اسرائيل هكذا هدد
رئيس الاتحاد العام لنقابات العمال
الاستدروت ويبدو انه فعل كل هذه الاضرابات
اثرت بشكل مباشر في سعر صرف الشيكل مقابل
الدولار انخفضت العمله الاسرائيليه لادنى
مستوى لها منذ ثلاثه اعوام هكذا تدخل
اسرائيل نفق المظلما يخيم على سير الحياه
مع لجوء الجميع الى الشارع تنكشف صوره
اخرى للدوله العبريه
ومن حيث معنى الان جاكي خوري الكاتب
المختص في الشؤون الاسرائيليه اهلا وسهلا
بك في الحصاد اذا هو ليس الصدام
الايديولوجي الاول بين الشارعين مختلفين
في اسرائيل ولكن يوصف بانه
الاخطر والاعنف لماذا ما الذي يختلف هذه
المره
الذي يختلف هذه المره ان الخلاف عمليا هو
ليس على قضيه تحمل القومي امام العدو
التقليدي في هذه الحاله العرب اذا كان على
مستوى الساحه الفلسطينيه او اي الساحه
اخرى في دول الجوار عاده المواجهات
والخلافات الكبيره داخل المجتمع
الاسرائيلي ارتبطت بحدث امني بشكل كبير
وهذا ثبت مثلا بعد الحرب في العام 73 بعد
ذلك الحرب في حرب لبنان الاولى بتداعيات
المجزره في صبرا وشاتيلا وصولا
بعد ذلك خطه فك الارتباط عن قطاع غزه كانت
صدماته في الماضي على المستوى الاجتماعي
عندما خرجت مجموعات شبابيه من اليهود
الشرقيين واصطدمت ايضا بالمؤسسه ولكن
المشهد الان يعني يتبلور وينحصر بشخص
يحاول السيطره على مقاليد الحكم باساليب
ديموقراطيه من خلال فوزه في صناديق
الاقتراع اولا ثانيا محاوله تمرير تفاصيل
ومشروع قانون لعمليه يحوله الى نوع من
يعني في البلد باعتبار انه يسيطر على
الجهاز القضائي كذلك تاثير المباشر على
الاعلام وعليه بدا المواطنه الاسرائيلي
يشعر ان هنالك امر ما وخلخله حتى في
الموازين على مستوى الديمقراطيه
الاسرائيليه يجب ان نوضح ان النظره في هذا
الموضوع هي ليست متعلقه بالعرب انما هي
خلاف اسرائيلي اسرائيلي
شيء جديد يعني لاول مره نرى خراطيم المياه
توجه نحو الاسرائيليين من الشرطه
الاسرائيليه نرى الخيال وما الى ذلك ولكن
اريد ان اسالك يعني فيما يتعلق بالاهتمام
بالش يعني انت تقول ديكتاتور فكره
الديكتاتور هذه هناك من يرحب بها داخل
اسرائيل بدليل ان هناك جزء من الشارع يخرج
ويصفق له ولكن وايضا يعني سمعنا لا تهتم
بالمعارضين هذه ليست اولويه واضح انه اهتم
من الذي يعني هل
هل هي التي لوت ذراعها هذه المره هل هو
الخوف من عصيان عسكري هو الذي حركه ليتحرك
بهذا الاتجاه الان
يعني اولا طبعا مصطلح الديكتاتور هو مرفوض
بنسبه نتنياهو مؤيديه هو يعتبر ان ما يذهب
باتجاه الان او ما حاول ان يمرروا في
الفتره القريبه وخطه اصلاح يعني يجب ان
ننتبه ايضا الى المصطلحات التي تستخدم
نتنياهو ونيفين وبنكفيل واخيرا يتحدثون عن
خطه اصلاح لجهاز القضاء لتقويه
الديمقراطيه بنظرهم في المقابل الطرف
الاخر يعتبر ان هذه الخطه تاتي للسيطره
على جهاز القضاء وبالتالي يعني منع اي
تصل للسلطات داخل المؤسسات الاسرائيليه
ولكن يعني الذي كما ذكرت له الذراع نتنياه
هنالك عده عوامل اولا البعد الامني بدون
شك خاصه وان التحذيرات والانذارات لم تاتي
فقط من سياسيين حتى لو كانوا جنرالات
سابقين في الجيش الاسرائيلي وفي المؤسسات
العسكريه وانما من يعملون الان ويقفون على
راس المؤسسه خاصه قائد الاركان الجهاز
الامن العام وقائد جهاز المساعد بالاضافه
طبعا وهذا عامل مهم الى الرافعه
الاقتصاديه عندما ينتهم ارباب الصناعه
والتجاره ومدراء البنوك وتبدا ايضا شركات
وهي طبعا تعتبر اسرائيل من الدول الحاضنه
والمهمه جدا تبدا بتصدير اموالها صح
التعبير واخراجها من البلاد الى بنوك في
دول اخرى واضح انه هذا مؤشر وبدا يظهر
ايضا من خلال طبعا قيمه الشيكل مقابل
الدولار وكذلك يعني في امور اقتصاديه حياه
هي ونتنياهو رجل اقتصادي ايضا يفهم
ويستطيع ان يقرا هذا الامر بالاضافه طبعا
الى العامل في الدول يجب ان ننتبه الى ان
وتيره الاحداث ارتفعت جدا بعد الاتصال
الهاتف الذي تم وكان اتصال مشحون كما يبدو
بين الرئيس الامريكي وبين نتالي ولكن
دائما السياسي عندما يواجه مشاكل في
الداخل يذهب يريد ان يصدر مشاكله وازم ته
للخارج انت كيف ترى نوع هذا التصدير من
وجهه نظرك كيف سيؤثر على اداء اسرائيل في
المرحله القادمه وايننا ستتجه
يعني من يعتقد ان الامور ستذهب مثلا الى
تصعيد في الضفه الغربيه بشكل كبير او
الذهاب الى نوع من المواجهه الشامله اذا
كان في قطاع غزه او في الحدود اللبنانيه
طبعا مع حزب الله يعني هذا المشهد الان
دعيني اقول لم ينضج الى مرحله ان تبدا
اسرائيل بعمليه عسكريه تصفها بالنوعيه ضد
هذه الاهداف على مستوى الضفه الغربيه يعني
لابد من التاكيد على هذا الامر عند
العمليات العسكريه مستمره بشكل شبه يومي
وبوتيره يعني تبدو شبه عاديه بالنظره
الاسرائيليه حتى مقارنه مع ما كان قبل عده
اشهر وقبل دخول هذه الحكومه وتبدا بمهامها
نعم كانت احداث صعبه ومؤلمه في نابلس
وكذلك في جنين ولكن هذا يعني من ناحيه
السياسات الامنيه العسكريه هي لم تختلف
كثيرا عندما كان بيني جانس ايضا وزيرا
للامن ويعير لابيد وزيره رئيسا للوزراء
وكذلك نفتالي بنت السياسه هي نفس السياسه
تقرا باسرائيل بانها مكافحه للارهاب
وبالتالي منع ووعد اي عمل بشكل استباقي
وهذا الامر مستمر بما في ذلك في هذا اليوم
كانت هنالك عمليه اقتحام في عقبه جبر في
اريحا وكذلك اعتقالات على مستوى الضفه
الغربيه ولكن المشهد العام هو ان هنالك
امور بدات تتغير داخل المؤسسه الامنيه
وهنالك تهديدات اقليميه كبيره خاصه ما
يرتبط بالملف اشكرك جاكي خوري الكاتب
المتخصص في الشؤون الاسرائيليه طبعا
تشاهدون الان على الشاشه
يعني الاضرابات والاحتجاجات مستمره دبابات
سيارات خراطيم المياه التي استخدمت كذلك
كما وصف احمد قبل قليل الخياله ايضا تحاول
تفريق
المتظاهرين ولكن يعودون للتجمع في كل مره
يتم تتم المحاوله فيها
اعاده الازمه الجاريه او في اسرائيل
السجال بشان عدم وجود دستور منذ انشاء
الدوله فلماذا لا يوجد دستور في اسرائيل
وكيف تنتظم العلاقه بين السلطات والفصل
بينها
منذ تاسيسها قبل نحو 75 عاما فوق اراضي
فلسطين التاريخيه لا تزال اسرائيل حتى
الان واحده من الدول القليله حول العالم
التي لا تمتلك دستورا رغم اصرار قادتها
على الترويج دائما بانهم الديمقراطيه
الوحيده في الشرق الاوسط واصطبحر من
الديكتاتوريات بحسب معجم الكنيسه
الاسرائيلي فان صعوبه وضع دستور تنبع من
وجهات النظر المختلفه بخصوص طبيعه دوله
اسرائيل كدوله يهوديه ديمقراطيه لذلك فان
حديث زعيم المعارضه الاسرائيليه يا
ايرلابيد بان المظاهرات الرافضه للتعديلات
القضائيه لن تتوقف حتى يكون لاسرائيل
دستور يعيد احياء ذات الجدل الذي تفجر
لاول مره او اخر عام
1948 اذ عرض مؤسس اسرائيل ديفيد بن غوريون
انذاك فكره وضع دستور لتخوفه من ان ذلك
الى تدمير الهويه اليهوديه للدوله الجديده
فرغم قله اليهود المتدينين في حينها فقد
رفضوا اي دستور يصوغه علمانيون لذلك اتفق
حينها على وضع ما يسمى قوانين الاساس وهي
قوانين بديله عن الدستور من اجل تحديد اسس
الحكم والعلاقه المتبادله بين السلطات
والحقوق الشخصيه وهذه القوانين لا يجوز
تغييرها او ابطالها في الكنيست الاسرائيلي
الا باغلبيه اعضائه اما لماذا يصعب حتى
اليوم وضع دستور في اسرائيل فقد ارجع عدد
من الباحثين في الشؤون الاسرائيليه ذلك
الى عده عوامل يتعلق جوهرها بالاختلاف على
هويه الدوله ومفهوم القوميه اليهوديه
والارض اليهوديه واي حسم دستوري في احدها
قد يؤدي وفق وجهه نظرهم لا تداعيات اعمق
من غياب الدستور نفسه فالدستور سيؤدي الى
تحديد حدود ثابته لاسرائيل ما يعني نهايه
لاحلام التوسع التي اعتاد قاده الصهيونيه
الدينيه في اقصى اليمين الحديث عنها فوزير
الماليه الاسرائيلي
تحدث قبل ايام قليله فوق منصه عليها خريطه
موسعه لاسرائيل تضم كامل الاردن والاراضي
الفلسطينيه المحتله كما ان وضع الدستور
سيجبر اسرائيل على تحديد تعريف ثابت لها
هل هي دوله علمانيه ديمقراطيه ام دوله
دينيه فيوقراطيه ما يهدد بحرب ثقافيه
ودينيه بين اليهود المتدينين والحريديين
من جهه واليهود العلمانيين واللبراليين
والاشتراكيين من جهه اخرى
ومن غزه معنا الدكتور صالح النعامي البحث
المختص في الشؤون الاسرائيليه اهلا بك
دكتور صالح سابدا من حيث انتهى التقرير
للتو التقرير كان يتحدث عن ما يهدد بحرب
ثقافيه دينيه بين اليهود
المتدينين واليهود العلمانيين
ولكن الرئيس الامريكي يرى ان ما يجري لن
يرقى لحرب اهليه عما نتحدث هنا هل فعلا
يمكن ان
يجري الصراع حاليا الى حرب اهليه
في الحقيقه استاذه ليلى حاله الاغتصاب
الداخلي والتشذ المجتمعي الذي تعاني
اسرائيل حاليا هو غير مسبوق بكل المقاييس
لم يحدث في تاريخ الكيان الصهيوني ان حدثت
ان حدث مثل هذا الصراع صراع الهويات على
صعيد
ما بين
ما بين اصحاب التوجهات الدينيه من اتباع
التيار الديني بشقيه الدين القومي والدين
الحديدي ومباين العلمانيين من جهه ومبين
الشرقيين من جهه والغربيين من جهه
الخلاف على الصحاحات القضائيه في الحقيقه
هو
ابرز حرب الهويات داخل داخل الكيان
الصهيوني بعدما فشل بعد ما تبين انه
استراتيجيه بوتقه السهر التي ارساها رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي الاول او مؤسس الكيان
الصهيوني دبيد بن غوريون لخلط
وتجميع الثقافات الثقافات التي جلبها
اليهود الذين هاجروا الى الى ارض فلسطين
بهدف الشيطانها واغتصابها
وانتاج الثقافه الاسرائيليه الواحده هذه
الاستراتيجيه الان فشلت فشلا ذريعا وقد
يكون ما حدث اثناء
وباء انتشار وباء كورونا في داخل كيان
الصناعي عندما يعني تمرد ما اشبه تمرد
التيار الحديدي على على الدوله وعلى نظمها
هذا يعني امتداد لهذا لفشل لهذه
الاستراتيجيه وما نشهد الان هو تعبير عن
هذا الامر النقطه المهمه يا استاذه ليلى
هو انه
المتغير الجديد هو شعور التيار الديني
بثقه كبيره بسبب الثقل الديموغرافي لهذا
التيار علينا الذكر التيار الديني تحديدا
متوسط عدد ولادات المراه المتدين الحارثيه
في اسرائيل ثمان ولادات وبالتالي هذا منح
ليس فقط يمنح هؤلاء ثقلا ديم بل ايضا
نفوذا سياسيا لذلك اذا تحدثنا في المرات
في الانتخابات القادمه سنجد وهذا ما يقوله
تقريبا اغلب علماء الاجتماع السياسي في
اسرائيل بانه اليمين الديني واليمين بشكل
عام سيعزز مكاسبه وبالتالي حتى اذا تجاوز
الاسرائيلي خلاف حول ولكن
باي ثمن يعني سمعه اسرائيل الان على المحك
النظره يعني العالم كله يراقب ما يجري
داخل اسرائيل الى اي حد داخل الاسرائيلي
ما قبل هذا التصعيد سيختلف عما هو عليه
بعد التصعيد
يعني تصوري حتى حتى الامس حتى مساء الامس
عندما يعني
ثار الاسرائيليون وقاموا بمظاهر احتجاج
غير مسبوقه وتوقع الناس وتوقع الكثيرون في
اسرائيل ان يكون اعلان بن يمين نتنياهو
اليوم عن وقف وانهاء
القضائيه على الرغم من تدهور الوضع
الاقتصادي وانخفاض قيمه الشيكل هروب
الشركات من داخل اسرائيل الى الخارج في ظل
حاله الرفض الخدمه العسكريه الواسع وغير
المسبوق
الرغم من التحذيرات من الحرب الاهليه ومع
ذلك من يمين نتنياهو اصر على اثار يعني
على فقط على مساله التاجيل تحت وطاه تحت
وطاه لهذا الاحتجازات وليس الغائها لماذا
لانه بين يمينه نتنياهو ليس فقط ان هذه
الصحافه القضائيه تخدم وتمنح مسارا
للافلات من المحاكم القضاء الفساد بل ان
شركائه بالتيار الديني الحديدي هم ايضا
معنيين الاصلاحات
قضيه تكريس الحق قضيه هل هو خائف فعلا من
الدخول الى السجن خائف من على ائتلافه
الحاكم درجه الخوف هنا ايهما اعلى في
النهايه هذا ما يتجسد ويتمخط بهذا التصعيد
شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور صالح النعامي كنت
معنا اذا الخبير في الشان الاسرائيلي
وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه تفاعلت مع موجه
الغضب التي خلفتها اقاله رئيسه الحكومه
الاسرائيليه لوزير الدفاع في الشارع
الاسرائيلي واجمعت تدخلات المتظاهرين
والعسكريين والسياسيين على ان الوضع الذي
تعيشه اسرائيل خطير
ويستدعي حلولا عاجلا
اقاله وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي هي ازمه
داخل الازمه دفعت بالاف الغاضبين الى
الشارع الذي يعيشوا منذ مده على ايقاع
الاحتجاجات على التعديلات القضائيه تفعل
الاعلام الاسرائيلي مع موجه الغضب التي
خلفت الاقاله ونقل غضب الشارع
لقد وجه رئيس الحكومه اليوم ضربه مؤلمه
لامن الدوله ولذلك لا يمكنه ان يستمر في
وظيفته نحن مستمرون حتى اسقاط الحكومه
يكفي لقد مللنا نحن نموت هنا وهم لا
يهتمون الا بالحفاظ على بيبي في الحكم ما
يهمهم هو الانقلاب دون ان يحاوروا احدا
خلال جلسات النقاش يحضر عسكريون سابقون
ولا يتردد بعضهم في مقارنه ما يجري بموجه
الربيع العربي التي يسمونها انقلابات
نحن نعيش ليله تاريخيه ودراماتيكيه نعيش
ازمه كبيره لم نشهد لها مثيلا الصور التي
نراها تذكرني بصور دول عربيه مجاوره خلال
الانقلابات خرجت الجماهير الفقيره لانها
رات رئيس الحكومه يفضل اخراس وزير الامن
وفصله على الامن القومي
يجلس سياسيون بدلوهم في هذا النقاش ولا
يترددون ايضا في التحذير من خطوره الاحداث
التي تشهدها اسرائيل
الدوله في خطر دوله اسرائيل تعيش الخطر
الاعظم منذ حرب يوم الغفران خطر اقتصادي
يهدد كل شيء وخطر سياسي وبالاساس خطر امني
يذهب محللنا كثر في الاعلام الاسرائيلي
الى ان اسرائيل لم تعش خطرا داخليا كهذا
من قبل ويحذرون بنيامين نتنياهو من
الاستمرار في نهجه الحالي
اعتقد ان بامكاننا الاشاره الى علامات
الوضع السيء الذي نعيشه التهديد الكبير
الذي كنا نخشاه من الخارج اصبح الان
تهديدا داخليا علينا ان نظهر موقفا صلبا
وموحدا للخارج حتى لا نجعل اعداءنا كايران
وحماس يعتقدون اننا نعاني ضعفا داخليا
تذهب تحليلات كثير من وسائل الاعلام
الاسرائيليه في اتجاه التحذير من الشرخ
الذي تشهده اسرائيل وتاثيره على صورتها في
المنطقه والعالم
[موسيقى]
قالت القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه
بينها العاصمه كيف ياتي هذا مع استمرار
الدعم الغربي لكياف ذكرت مجله
الالمانيه اليوم نقلا عن مصادر لم تسميها
ان المانيا سلمت اوكرانيا 18 دبابه من
طراز لافرد اثنين تعهدت بتقديمها لدعمك في
حرب هذا روسيا واضافت المجله ان نحو 40
عربه مشاه قتلي قتاليه المانيه من طراز
ماردر وصلت الى اوكرانيا بالفعل
اما الكرملين فقال انه لا نيه لديه لتغيير
الخطط العسكريه في اوكرانيا وان كل
الخيارات مطروحه للرد على العقوبات
الغربيه يتزامن هذا واستمرار موسكو في
استعداداتها لنشر اسلحه النوويه
تكتيكيه في اراضي بيلاروسيه وسط غضب غربيا
متزايد
لن نتراجع موقف في جمله ترددها موسكو
وتكررها على مسامع حلفائك في الحرب
الدائره والحروب الموازيه
لتغيير الخطط العسكريه في اوكرانيا اكد
الكريم محذرا من ان روسيا لا تستبعد اي
خيار للرد على العقوبات خيار التحالف
الوثيق مع بيلاروسيا في زمن الحرب يترجم
بافعال تثير حافظته حلف شمال الاطلس
والاتحاد الاوروبي وكل الداعمين لاوكرانيا
وهذا فيديو نشرته وزاره الدفاع
البيلاروسيه يظهر مقاطع لتدريبات تضم وحده
دفاع جوي لانظمه صواريخ تور المتقدمه من
روسيا التوقيت رساله اخرى غير مشفره بعد
يومين فقط من اعلان الرئيس فلاديمير بوتين
عن خطط لنشر اسلحه نوويه تكتيكيه في
بيلاروسيا كشف حينها عن جدول زمونيين لتلك
الخطوه المستهجنه من الغرب
اعتبارا من الثالث ابريل المقبل ستبشر
روسيا تدريب الفرق وفي الاول من يوليو
ستبني مستودعا خاصا للاسلحه النوويه على
اراضي بيلاروسيا
بالنسبه لموسكو هذا رد على اعلان لندن
تزويد بذخائر باليورانيوم المنظم الهدف من
الدعم الغربي لاوكرانيا واحد اوضح وزير
الخارجيه
بتقديم دعم واسع مالي وعسكري وسياسي لنظام
الغرب يقوم بذلك لهدف واحد ومهمه اعلن
عنها هي الحاق هزيمه استراتيجيه وتدمير
الاقتصاد الروسي وخلق حاله من عدم الرضا
لدى السكان على خلفيه سوء الاوضاع
وبالتالي زعزعه الاستقرار الداخلي
موقف وزير الشؤون الاتحاد الاوروبي في
بولندا بشان ازمه الاسلحه النوويه
التكتيكيه بدم هادنا مقارنه بردود الفعل
التي اعقبت اعلان بوتين قال الوزير شيمونس
ان على الغرب التزام الهدوء في رده على
قرار روسيا نشر اسلحه نوويه التكتيكيه في
بيلاروسيا واضاف ان القرار الروسي هو عنصر
تصعيد ويجب ان يكون رد الفعل هادئا لكن
حازما
على الارض مزيد من المعارك والدمار
والضحايا في جبهات بخموت وخركيف ودنيتك
يقول كل طرف انه كبد الاخر خسائر فاتحه
هنا وهناك في اوكرانيا وروسيا جنازات قتل
الحرب حرب في ابعادها وتداعياتها وتعدد
اطرافها عالميه حتى وانتفاد الجميع
اعتمادها الوصف
الحديث عن النووي التكتيكي والفرق بينه
وبين السلاح الاستراتيجي ومن هي الدول
التي تمتلكه موضوع سنناقشه بعد قليل في
فقره المتابعه
[موسيقى]
الى السودان الان حيث حصلت الجزيره على
مسوده الاتفاق السياسي النهائي بين
العسكريين في السلطه والقوى المدنيه
الموقعه على الاتفاق الايطالي جاء في
المسوده انهم من الضروري انجازوا الاصلاح
الامني بما يقود الى جيش مهنيا موحد ينقى
عن السياسه والاعمال التجاريه
والاستثماريه وتناولت مسوده الاتفاق تفكيك
النظام السابق ومراجعه قرارات قائد الجيش
في سياق اجراءات الخامس والعشرين من
اكتوبر تشرين الاول 2021 كما دعت مسوده
الاتفاق الى اطلاق عمليه شامله في السودان
تحقق العداله والعداله الانتقاليه لكشف
الجرائم ومحاسبه مرتكبها نصا الاتفاق
السياسيه على ثلاثه مستويات للحكم هي
المستوى الفيدرالي المستوى الاقليمي كذلك
الحكم المحلي وقد سلمت المسوده لقاده
الجيش والدعم السريع والقوى السياسيه
لابداء الملاحظات عليها قبل التوقيع
النهائي مطلع ابريل نيسان المقبل
وكانت قد اختمت في الخرطوم اعماله ورشه
الاصلاح العسكري والامني وهي الورشه
الاخيره من بين خمس ورش عمل تعرف باسم ورش
ومؤتمرات المرحله النهائيه للعمليه
السياسيه وهي ورش اتفق اتفق عليها ضمن
متطلبات الاتفاق الايطالي السياسي الموقع
بين المدنيين والعسكريين في ديسمبر كانون
الاول الماضي وشارك في الورشه ممثلوا
القوات النظاميه والقوات السياسيه وحركات
الكفاح المسلح ومتقاعدون القوات النظاميه
وطيف من المختصين الوطنيين
ومعنى الان من الخرطوم محمد المبروك
الكاتب الصحفي اهلا وسهلا بك استاذ محمد
اذا هل ترى
النهايه للنفق المظلم هل سيخرج السودان
اخيرا من هذا النفق هلا تم الاتفاق على كل
النقاط التي كانت موضع خلاف
مساء الخير وشكرا للاستضافه طيب نعم هناك
هناك هناك الضوء في اخر النفق وهذه
الخطوات السياسيه الاخيره هي خطوات تبدو
جاده جدا خصوصا عفوا بعد مشاركه المكون
العسكري الواضحه في ورشه الاصلاح الامن
العسكري التي بدت الشكوك التي كانت قائمه
تجاه
قبول المكون العسكري بهذه العمليه
السياسيه او تحفظات بعض غاده الجيش على
هذه العمليه السياسيه بهذا الشكل بما فيهم
قائده الجيش الفريق عبد الفتاح البرهان
بالتالي نعم نحن امام مرحله سياسيه جديده
ربما هذه المرحله السياسيه جديده
تخرج السودان من الازمه السياسيه الحاليه
الى افق جديد والى طريق التحول الديمقراطي
ولكن هذه العمليه السياسيه في راي ليست
الاشكال الجوهري فيها هو المسودات التي تم
الاتفاق عليها او مسوده الاتفاق النهائي
التي تمت الاشاره اليها قبل قليل
الافتت هذه الاتفاقيات هو اطرافها وليس
مضمونه الازمه الحاليه التي تواجه العقبات
التي تواجه هذه العمليه السياسيه هي
الاطراف وليس المضمون المضمون ليس هناك
خلاف
الخلاف حول الاطراف وما هو هذا الخلاف
المعارضه في موقفها وايضا هناك المجلس
المركزي الذي يبدو وكانه صامد وقوي والصلب
هل سيحافظ على وحدته بعد هذا الاتفاق
وماذا عن خيارات المعارضه طيب لو نظرت الى
المسوده استاذه ليلى لو نظرت الى المسوده
الموجوده امامك الان اطراف العمليه
السياسيه هذه الاطراف مفترض تكون ثلاثه
اطراف اول حاجه المجلس المركزي الحريه
والتغيير طرف اول الطرف الثاني
المكونات الكتله الديمقراطيه او او مكونات
سلام جبله لان سلام جبلا جزء من هذا
الاتفاق بالتالي لا يتصور عمليا ان تكون
هناك عمليه سياسيه وتشكيل حكومه مدنيه في
غياب اطراف اتفاقيه جمل اللي موجوده
لاتفاق نفسه موجود داخل هذه المسوده الطرف
الثالث هو بطبيعه الحال
المنظومه الامنيه بكامله الجيش والمخابرات
العامه والدعم السريع اذا هناك طرف ناقص
الان هذا الطرف الناقص عدم وجوده بيعني ان
لا يعني ان العمليه السياسيه ستتوقف ربما
تسبب العمليه السياسيه الى نهايتها ورب
تشكل الحكومه مدنيه كما شكلت حكومه مدنيه
من قبل في 2019 ولكن في النهايه ستترك
وراءك غور سياسيه مؤثره جدا وستترك وراك
قوى سياسيه يمكن ان تضع
هذا الاتفاق الايطالي في في وضع ضيق جدا
باحت ممكن ان تتحالف مع قوه اخرى نعم نعم
كان بودي ان نستمر في هذا اللقاء ولكن
انتهى الوقت شكرا جزيلا محمد مبروك الكاتب
الصحفي من الخرطوم
[موسيقى]
اكد وزير الخارجه الايراني حسين امير
عبداللهيان تسلم الرئيس ابراهيم رئيسي
دعوه من العاهل السعودي لزياره المملكه
واضاف عبد الهيان في مقابله مع الجزيره
انا طهران سترد على ذلك بدعوه مماثله
عندما يصل الامر الى ترتيب مكاني وتاريخ
عقد اللقاء فان المهمه هنا هو تنفيذ
الاتفاق الذي جرى التوصل اليه من قبل قاده
الدولتين لقد رايتم في الايام القليله
الماضيه ان الملكه السعوديه وجه دعوه
رسميه للرئيس رئيسي لزياره المملكه
العربيه السعوديه وسوف نرد بالمثل بتوجيه
الدعوه للملك السعودي لزياره ايران
وبخصوص قضيه تبادل السجناء مع الولايات
المتحده قال عبد الحيان ان ذلك مرهون
بنتائج المفاوضات غير المباشره والتي جرت
في الاسابيع الماضيه مشيدا بالدور الذي
لعبته قطر في هذا الشان
معاذ
منذ مارس 2022 كانت هناك مذكره تتعلق
بقضيه تبادل السجناء مع الولايات المتحده
وفي الاسابيع القليله الماضيه وبغيت تحديث
المذكرات تبادلنا عددا من الرسائل الشفويه
مع الولايات المتحده قضيه تبادل السجناء
هي قضيه انسانيه بالكامل وطهران مستعده في
اطار المفاوضات والاتفاق الذي ابرم في
السابق لكن هذا يعتمد على نتيجه المفاوضات
غير المباشره المستمره طوال الاسابيع
الماضيه بين الطرفين ان تبادل السجناء
قضيه منفصله عن الاتفاق النووي وهناك
قضايا فنيه نامل الانتهاء منها قطر كانت
تبذل جهودا بناء فيما يتعلق بالمحادثات
التي اجريت سابقا بشان تبادل السجناء
والاتفاق النووي وهي ما تزال مستمره في
ذلك
العوده الى الجدل بشان استخدام السلاح
النووي التكتيكي اثراء اعلاني موسكو عزمها
نشر بعض من الرؤوس في بيلاروسيا سلاح نووي
تكتيكي ما الذي يعنيه ذلك ما الفرق بينه
وبين السلاح النووي الذي اعتدنا السماع
عنه في المبدا الفرق يكمن في الحجم وغرض
الاستخدام ومكان الهدف بالنسبه للحجم فان
القدره التدميريه لاصغر راس تفجيري لسلاح
نووي تصل الى كيلوتن واحد او اقل واكبرها
مئه كيلو طن اما السلاح النووي
الاستراتيجي فقد تصل قواته التدميريه الى
الف كيلو طن
للتوضيح فان الكيلوتون ينتج قوه تدميريه
تعادل 1000 طن من ماده تي ان تي المتفجره
السلاح النووي التكتيكي مخصص للاستخدام في
ساحه المعركه او بتوجيه ضربه محدوده للعدو
دون التسبب في تداعيات اشعاعيه واسعه
النطاق بينما يستخدم السلاح الاستراتيجي
للمسافات البعيده ولضرب العمق ولكن من
يمتلك هذا السلاح
الولايات المتحده
بنحو 230 سلاح نوويا تكتيكيا نشرت جزء من
مخزونها في ايطاليا في تركيا في بلجيكا
وهولندا كذلك اما روسيا
تحدثت الاحصائيات عن نحو الفين من هذه
الرؤوس النوويه التكتيكيه واخر الاخبار عن
نشر بعض منها في بيلاروسيا تحديدا تبقى
هناك باكستان والصين والهند واسرائيل
وكوريا الشماليه كل هذه الدول لديها انواع
متعدده من هذه الاسلحه النوويه التكتيكيه
المقارنه بين التكتيكي والاستراتيجي هي في
الحقيقه مقارنه بين الاسوا والاكثر سوءا
اذ يعتبر الخبراء ان كل تلك الاسلحه فتاكه
والهدف من استخدامها احداث تغيير
استراتيجي في اي مواجهه محتمله
القصف النووي الامريكي لهيروشيما ونجازاكي
في اليابان عام 45 من القرن الماضي كان
بقبلتين نوويتين تكتيكيتين الاولى قوتها
التفجيريه نحو 15 كيلو الثانيه 21
كيلو طن
القنبلتان الامريكيتان قتلت اكثر من مئه
الف شخص فورا ومات عشرات الالاف لاحقا
بسبب الاشاعات
في محاكاه لصراع امريكيه الروسيه اجرتها
جامعه فلسطين في الولايات المتحده اظهرت
هذه الدراسه ان استخدام سلاح نووي تكتيكي
قد يخلف اكثر من 90 مليون قتيل ومصاب
اذا سنناقش هذه هذا الموضوع مع ضيفنا من
بيروت العميد الياس حنا الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي الان الحديث اذا عميد الياس
اهلا بك عن السلاح تكتيكي وسلاح استراتيجي
وتهديد بانه روسيا قد تجر الى هذه النقطه
وترسل رساله للعالم كلها انها يعني علي
ولا على اعدائي ساقدم على الخطوه ما
تعليقك
ليلى لا نزال في القرار القرار اتى من
الرئيس هناك اليه لنشرها هناك اليه وتعديل
للعقيده العسكريه في كيفيه الاستعمال مع
من ستكون من هو المسؤول هل سيعطي الرئيس
بوتين كما قال تدريب عشره طائرات
بيلاروسيه وخاصه ليلى بالعام 96 تخلت
بيلاروسيا عن وحده وثمانين راس نووي
اعدتهم الى
روسيا كما فعلت اوكرانيا بالعام 94 فاذا
نحن امام مرحله جديده امام رساله ندعيه من
نوع جديد الجديد هو في النشر وقرار النشر
ولكن يجب ان ننتظر الى مؤشراتها طيب ما
الذي يمكن ان يجر روسيا لكي تقدم على هذه
الخطوه وماذا يمكن ان ننتظر منها
حسب العقيده الروسيه اي هدف اي تهديد
تقليدي ليلى في محيط روسيا يهدد الكيان
ووحده الارض قد ياتي يؤدي الى استعمال
السلاح دمر رئيس بوتين اربعه اقاليم اذا
حاول الغرب اوكرانيا على سبيل المثال
الحصر تحريرها فانما يهدد بمعنى وبالمفهوم
الروسي يهدد الارض الروسيه وقد يؤدي الى
الاستعمال ولكن ليله يجب ان نفرق ان سلاح
التكتيكي هو ذات قيمه استراتيجيه يؤدي الى
تفاعلات استراتيجيه حتى
هيروشيماكي التفاعلات والنتائج اتت
استراتيجيه لانها وقفت الحرب واستسلمت
اليابان يعني لا يمكن ان نقول عنا سلاح
تكتيكي لان النتيجه كانت استراتيجيه
الهايمرس لديه نتائج استراتيجيه وهو سلاح
تقليدي فاذا الحديث عن تكتيكي على مسرح
بسيط مثل اوكرانيا هو شيء بعيد يستخدم
يعني هل ترى ما يؤشر الى امكانيه
استخدامها من روسيا في القريب
حتى الان لا يمكن استخدامها اصلا ليست
جاهزه وليس لدى الغرب والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه مؤشرات عن تحريك هذه القذائف
هذه القنابل القنبله بحاجه الى راس نووي
بحاجه الى وسيله لارسالها نقلها ومن ثم
ادخالها في المنظومه الجديده وهذا امر لم
يحدث بعد شكرا جزيلا لحسن الحظ انه لم
يحدث ولن نرجو ان لا يحدث ابدا شكرا سياده
العميد الياس حنا من بيروت
لهذا ننهي جوله الحصاد الليله
وسنترككم مع الجلال وسلمى في جوله منتصف
الليل شكرا جزيلا على المتابعه وفي من